so when it moves it's changing the route
to get between two nodes when it flashes
it disappears
and then there we are that's it gone
and the world is free of facebook if a
tree falls
a dream takes
does the tree exist but no one knows
because no one's seen the fact
what are they going to be saying
in silicon valley this morning i'm not
sure we can put that on a family
friendly church
once upon a time not so long ago there
was a little website and its name was
facebook
and then it stopped
it ceased to be it ceased to be took
along instagram and whatsapp with it
and uh yeah so a bit of excitement for
those network nerds last night as we
watched facebook
disconnect from the internet
the first thing to say is that facebook
know what they're doing when it comes to
networking they're designing their own
gear they're designing their own
switches their own routers they're
writing their own operating systems on
top of linux to run these things they're
not some fly by night operation that
don't know what they're doing here
the big the thing that's probably
happened here is that someone's had a
bad day at work they've pushed something
up to the servers and to the switches
and things and it just didn't work
and normally when you do that it sort of
you get a slight error message someone
yesterday probably pushed the wrong
button and brought down the whole of
zuckerberg's empire what was interesting
about it from a networking point of view
is just exactly what
happened this wasn't a case of
um you couldn't access the website it
wasn't responding but the computers were
still there
facebook literally managed to disconnect
themselves from the internet the stories
coming out from journalists in states
and things is that facebook engineers
couldn't get into the building because
their cards weren't being swiped which
you can start to understand why that
would be the case when you've got a such
a large network that you're dealing with
and they like to eat their own dog food
and so their whole network is built on
top of their own infrastructure when you
get as something as catastrophic as this
happen
then it's going to be a big problem for
them so the big question then of course
is what actually happened i'm using the
right bgp replay to look at this i've
pre-recorded it so i can skip through it
if we run back in time we can get to
around three o'clock gmt what we've got
here is the network where facebook's dns
server is so dns is the system which
takes the name facebook.com and converts
it to the ip address that facebook uses
so watch mike's video on that so dns
acts a bit like a phone book you can
look up
facebook.com when you get an ip address
back well people actually know what a
phone book is these days uh well
somewhere older viewers will youtubers
might need to know that it's a book that
have telephone numbers yeah
dns is the bit of the internet that
converts names facebook.com
instagram.comwhatsapp.com
into the ip addresses of the servers
that convert that so what we've got on
screen here is this is the network that
facebook's main dns server is on and why
that's important
is when you request
facebook.com or whichever one it is you
want to go to or your phone's app
requests it it'll end up talking to that
probably indirectly by your isp getting
the ip address from that and then it
will make a connection to that ip
address to actually connect to the thing
so before your computer connects
to facebook's computer it asks where
facebook is this red dot is the network
that facebook's dns serves on these
other dots are just other networks on
the internet so different isps and
things we've got cogent over here i
think it's tellia over there in sweden
and things different isps
that are providing things and if you
look at it on a normal day
facebook is very very well connected
they have direct network connections
they peer as the terminology is in the
networking industry
with
pretty much anyone who will appear with
them and things so rather than having to
connect to someone else
you connect directly to facebook there's
a bit of fiber optic between the two of
you and the data travels that way that's
how they can cope with the sheer amount
of bandwidth from everyone checking
their phone what we see happening
is quite interesting it's actually a
really good example of how the internet
can cope with disruption
because if we just scroll forward in
time
we can see that as things start to
happen we get to this point where
everything starts to reroute and rather
than going directly to facebook you can
start to see it all is going to cogent
and telia and then as we go a bit
further on we suddenly see that
everything starts to disappear
until you get to a point there we are
where there's
nothing connected to facebook except
there's one machine down here there's
one network and suddenly facebook's
network the network that runs
all facebook's computers are on is
completely disconnected from the
internet
and so when you go to look at
facebook.com the compute your computer
cannot find out
where the machine is on the internet so
it can't even send a packet there saying
connect to facebook not that facebook
would be there to connect to because it
doesn't know where it is so at about
what we're looking about sort of 1627
gmt yesterday afternoon 10th 4th of
october 2021
facebook had effectively disconnected
themselves from the internet their
computers were no longer connected
to the internet now this isn't the case
of someone going around along pulling
all the ethernet cables out pulling all
the fiber optics out and physically
disconnecting them now this is a
configuration error in a protocol called
bgp for border gateway protocol 4
version 4. and this is a protocol that's
used to
it's used by the routers that connect
networks together so rather than having
a sort of static map of if you want to
get from a to b you go down this route
then that route then that route the
computers configure themselves
automatically they're constantly
refreshing things as the situation
changes on the internet so
a network link may go down someone might
put a jcb through a fork through a fibre
optic
might misconfigure a server or
that
link may just have a lot of data
transmitting across it in which case
it's better to root it via a different
route because it will get there faster
because it's not to deal with the
contention on that link so you need to
continuously recalculate
which route to take so that it you get
the best performance out of it
and to do that you need to know
where everything is on the internet so
you can work out which is the best route
to take at this point now if it was
static you could use something like
dijkstra's algorithm which mike's talked
about run that on all the data and you
can work out the quickest route things
like auto route or google maps they will
often do it like that they'll use an
algorithm like that because the road
network static you know where everything
is you know the sort of capacity of it
uh and things and so you can work out
the route beforehand with the internet
we
want to do things dynamically and so
rather than
storing everything statically each of
the routers on the internet are
communicating with each other using the
border gateway protocol for to tell them
what they can see and where they can get
to and what the cost of going that way
is and things and they're exchanging
this information and so the router will
get information from
this another router and it says okay i
can get to let's say facebook this way
by that machine
but the cost of going that way is low is
higher than the cost of going by the
direct link i've got so i'll send my
packet via the direct link
and so it sends it that way what we saw
here is that suddenly those direct links
started disappearing so as the direct
link disappeared it said well actually i
can't get that way anymore i'll go this
way which is why we saw that
suddenly it went from everyone going to
facebook
to at this point you're starting to go
through a few people who are now saying
i can go that way and it sort of
concentrates to a certain sets of routes
now why did that happen
well as part of bgp4 the machines are
announcing that they can get somewhere
and that this network is at the other
end of this thing and what seems to have
happened
is that around
sort of three four o'clock gmt yesterday
facebook stopped announcing
the routes to their network
so they stopped saying to the routers
they were connected to hey you can reach
facebook 129.134.30.12
here
and things they stopped announcing that
you could reach things there so
as soon as they stopped announcing it
the routers they were connected to said
well i can't get to it that way because
it's not being announced anymore that
was a a stale route it doesn't exist
anymore i'll go this way because that is
still saying i can reach you that way
because you've got propagation times
rooter a
which is facebook say tells router b
and it tells root to c but root of c is
also telling root of b you can reach
there and so you've got to wait for it
to update and propagate round so you get
this sort of effect where suddenly you
get roots that probably don't exist it's
not that they could probably reach
facebook at this point
it's actually that
they still think i thought they could
when they told this machine that they
could but actually by the time it
updates
they couldn't reach there and that's
when you get things suddenly
disappearing completely and facebook's
no longer accessible because they're not
announcing that they exist technically
the machine is probably never
disconnected from the internet if you
knew that you could send it to this
machine
and then that would pass it on to
facebook you probably have hacked a
static route into your machine and if
your isp did it as well and actually got
the data to facebook
um
but to do that you need to know these
things and then you have to manually
configure it and that's what probably
what got facebook into the problem in
the first place is changing the
configuration on the bgp things now why
would that have an effect internally
well there's probably two things that
probably at play here
facebook.com probably used the same dns
servers to store their internal things
as well
and when they did a lookup upon them
they weren't connected to internet so
they couldn't access them
but i suspect the other thing is is that
often when you've got a big network and
facebook do have a big network they have
thousands and probably tens if not
hundreds of thousands of machines
working on their network
you probably end up building your own
internet type network internally
facebook google apple microsoft all of
these they're of such a size amazon that
they will have their own effectively
mini internet um and networks of
networks internet working which is where
the name comes from
internally and so
they will use ibgp they'll use bgp
internally or ibgp which is the one
designed for
interior networks and i imagine that the
same configuration changes which made it
drop the announcements
externally probably had a similar effect
internally so you're sitting at your
desk and you realize facebook's gone
down so you ssh into the server that you
need to configure
but the router that you're connected to
doesn't know where to send that packet
to because it suddenly no longer knows
where things are and then
you probably can't make the voip voice
over iphone call to the person who uh
can switch things back on and you've
suddenly got a chicken and egg situation
how do we communicate
um without facebook and all the tools we
use when our network's down when
everything communicates over our network
so how do we bring it back up i did hear
one thing where
apparently the people who had physical
access to the
servers to battery and the switches to
reboot them didn't have the credentials
to do so and the people who had the
credentials couldn't communicate with
the
things because they couldn't get into
the building to get the credentials and
whether that's true or not or just so
rumors flying around on hacker news and
things is a another
story facebook would have needed to roll
things back and then to start
re-advertising their routes and which is
what happened
about nine o'clock gmt last night they
started to re-advertise things then they
went down again and then they sort of
came back up as they sort of
reconfigured things so basically
configuration error took it completely
out uh because they just effectively
disconnected themselves from the
internet accidentally instead of
i guess it's the sort of bgp equivalent
of tripping over the network cable on
the way out the door and sort of
somebody suggested it was like locking
your car keys in the boot and not having
that yeah
so it's a bit like that sort of
situation i need this to get get things
restarted but i can't get that because i
can't access it
internally because the network's down
externally because the network's down
and things what do you think they'll do
after this
secondary dns servers what do you reckon
uh so i mean this is an interesting
question there's going to be
um i mean let's let's not forget this is
an extraordinary event facebook have a
very resilient network
they have good disaster management
things we probably
things like this happen all the time
internally and we just don't notice it
this just happened to be the one event
that
everything aligned in the wrong way and
things weren't wrong uh and and it
became big
literally big news when you sort of no
one can well it would have been big news
if anyone could actually tell anyone but
because once that was down people
wouldn't be able to tell each other what
was going on it's sort of yeah until
computer file comes out with the news
but there'll be different procedures put
in place for how you update the servers
and things to make sure this doesn't
happen again but
the thing is you're not going to get 100
right there's no way you can
get it 100 right because there'll always
be some situation um where someone could
go wrong someone on twitter suggested
that there should be a sort of five
minute period where if he's not
confirmed after that it reverts back to
the original configuration you know a
bit like when you change the display in
windows you get that sort of confirm
within 10 seconds so you can see things
the problem with that is that's fine
if it's
a problem that will occur within those
five minutes
if it requires some set of conditions
that happen aft in the sixth minute
you've got the same situation you can
make it slightly better but and i'm sure
they actually do have procedures similar
to that but there's always something
that can go wrong i mean for our point
of view for people who use facebook or
for those of you who use instagram or
whatsapp
it perhaps should make us think
about
the way that people build these tools i
mean this wouldn't have happened in the
same way to email
it would be very much harder for someone
to bring email down in the same way
because
the servers are all run by different
people and
if you send an email to me it talks to
my server whereas if you send an email
to someone on gmail it talks to gmail
server if you talk to someone at the
university of nottingham it talks to
someone on well actually microsoft
server because they're supporting the
network for it and so on but you might
lose gmail or you might lose my server
or
whatever but you wouldn't lose the whole
lot in one go
the problem here is all our eggs are in
one facebook basket
do not try this at home
only try this at home oh yeah that's a
very good try this at home but not
anywhere else realistic random number
generator in the sense that if you're in
some state and you've got your rule
you're always going to produce the exact
same state that you had before right it
seems obvious so this repeats itself
after what